you don't need your validation or
happiness to come from anything that has
to do with anything of your friend's
life you have to do what makes you happy
so that
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
it's Friday Black Friday
back at my pops shop from 11 to 2. can't
wait to see all of you selfies q a we've
got a special empathy sparkling wine
that is only exclusive at blind library
on the side of those bottles come
through if you're in the area I'm
excited it should be a lot a lot a lot
of fun I love you I'll see you
thanks for being number one in line the
first in line because guess what there's
no second place trophies I'd love to
give you a gift please if you don't mind
this is an authenticated Shaquille
O'Neal autographed PSA 10 card for you
guys thank you my man and to also one up
myself I have a gift for all the crew
over here wow because guess what it
takes a team to win the championship
baby it's true you know Gary brother
nice to meet you oh my gosh keep up the
great work Gary I came across your
content when I was in a dark place top
three people would have had a need and
personally I'm glad thank you for being
here it's an honor it's a real pleasure
thank you take a photo
and you know I learned to have my
balance last year I learned to have my
balance of rough moments or when to
sacrifice each for my purpose look in
the perspective my economical
perspective and all the things I wanted
like how [ __ ] up you think I am I
don't think you're [ __ ] up at all I
think it's a cliche ambitious immigrant
perspective I lived it the biggest thing
that can [ __ ] you up because you're not
[ __ ] up is lack of patience so I
wanted to say thank you for everything
you do for people I love how you help
kids understand our teacher I'm a
firefighter I love it I love it as an
artist I want to give you this damn this
is [ __ ] amazing thank you brother
this is beautiful in your podcast you
say you're a firefighter yes Jersey City
I love this I can't wait to rock this
thank you brother yeah yeah and I'm
gonna rip it out and um frame it it's
something that
something that we were told to do by
somebody I love it
I know you're gonna do that thank you
it's just ridiculous I mean if you don't
execute on your gratitude what are you
doing that's true but a lot of people
don't I'm very aware I'm very aware of
my friends it's great to see you again
Brian thank you so much
every every time it feels insane it
built it changed the way you looked at
it because it's real it is you know it's
[ __ ] crazy how real that is means a
lot to me brother love you bro for real
actually life is actually what you
decide it is from the way you look at it
you decide it's bad it's bad you decide
it's good it's good it's really that
[ __ ] simple which is insane it's like
really almost like challenging to like
believe it but it's just reality
[Music]
hi everyone
thank you for coming I need everybody
who's hanging out here to walk in line
and tell everybody there's no way we're
going to get to everybody if not
everybody is spending 30 seconds one
minute 30 seconds one minute how did you
like manage to prioritize things because
like I guess I guess there's no right
answer I just did what felt right the
Sid's so mad at me like
I can't help but doing what feels right
like trouties in the corner not doing
[ __ ] but I'm not mad at him I'm just
trying to do what I'm doing the only way
to really win the game the way I did it
with my dad here and the way I did it
with my brother and Vayner was just over
communicating like as hard as it is the
only answer to the family business quiz
is over communicating with love
[Music]
he was talking about her like younger
kids like it's okay to fail it's okay to
make mistakes it's okay to be lost when
you're trying to learn how to figure out
this world so a hundred percent you know
what's so funny it's not even being lost
people are like I'm lost you're not lost
you're just in the process yeah okay
nobody's [ __ ] lost you know what I
mean that's like a incredibly like
custom like everyone's like I'm lost I'm
like you're not lost you're just in the
process
what's up brother thank you because two
years ago I watched your trash talk
video yes last year I did fifty thousand
dollars say that one more time for all
the people at home so 20 years ago I got
into flipping stuff based on Gary's
Trash Talk video I did 50k in sales last
year it was truly incredible this guy
starting over like congratulations yeah
I mean it was like that's literally what
I say it's more tough to say in
something you don't love than the fear
of trying to find something you love so
the answer of you walking away from your
job on Wednesday what do I say I say
[ __ ] congratulations
how did you get past the Immigrant
family idea of you know go get your
education stay in your lane use your
education and don't venture out go make
that money bring it by understanding
that I'm so scared to be resentful of my
family that if I listen to them the only
outcome is resentment because if the
light is drawing me into a different
direction you're willing to deal with
the short-term pain of them being upset
with what you're doing to save you from
the long-term pain of you having a
problem forever because you listen to
them we end up being 40 years old 35
years old and being mad at them forever
because we listen to them instead of
following our dreams in our 20s
that's where you're at you need to
protect your relationship with your
family by not listening to them
thank you you're welcome
[Music]
nice to meet you nice to meet you I'm a
cancer survivor it's a real honor to
meet you King tell her to meet you too
and I'm the kid who puts your toys in my
activity it's a real honor it's great to
see you is this your crew who's this hi
nice to meet you so nice to meet you so
what's good bro it's good to see you
King it's a real pleasure how you
feeling
I'm just feeling well I'm still
suffering the side effects I understand
my man I mean your real inspiration my
dude thank you your inspiration to me
too
[Music]
my man thank you man you have no idea
how honored I am thank you for taking
the time to see my son of course it
means a lot um we do a lot for the
community we do a lot of giving back yes
we're blessed to have him I lost my mom
to cancer so giving back is a big thing
and we know you're a giver and we're a
great inspiration role model thank you
you know you're the definition of
getting it done and making no excuses so
and he brought some of these you want me
to sign them yeah of course one of them
he wants to give to a kid in the
hospital of course
[Music]
you need to put out content about your
learnings
as posts on LinkedIn you will be stunned
how much opportunity that will create
stories of a Salesman post that on
LinkedIn Another Story Another Story
Another Insight another observation
you'll be shocked what that can lead to
okay awesome gotta go on the offense
when this happens to you awesome right
yeah thank you man you're welcome thank
you very much I just want to say that
like you can please
I was in a dark time and I was
struggling with drugs and it was hard it
was hard on my family of course
I'm grateful that I was able to resonate
with your content and able to see that
I'm better than that 100 I just want
this message to go out to like all the
people at home to let them know that
they're not alone everyone was like you
should check out garyvee I think you
like it you relate with them a lot I
love it brother I'm so proud of you it's
so hard I so admire you I'm really happy
to see you I'm really happy that you
made it what are you doing now I'm
actually not working do you want to
apply at vaynermedia
that's part of the car yeah it's in the
card thank you such a pleasure
68 minutes okay we have 125 people
waiting okay that means 30 seconds you
gotta tell you got to tell everybody
okay
yes
your advice to realize that you actually
have an unbelievable amount of time to
start over the reality is is that it's
zero to Young 49 is we didn't think that
when you know I'm 47 we didn't think
that when we were 18. right but it's
true right and so like the biggest piece
of advice is understanding that you
literally have 50 [ __ ] more years
right and I'm going through the college
process activities many advice on don't
over stress yourself do the best you
[ __ ] can the [ __ ] gonna happen yeah
what what can you do you're gonna do the
best you [ __ ] can it's gonna play out
the waves to play out and then you've
got your whole life in front of you yeah
so just don't get yourself too worked up
thank you pleasure okay all right let's
go very sweet hey everybody I'm gonna
run through right now Jesus you're out
of control thank you
thank you for coming Hi how are you it's
so good to see you too how are things
really well thank you for coming thanks
for waiting in line for so long
let me take this this is my little one
how are you
hi little one yeah thanks for coming to
say thanks because uh no I'm like in my
later years but I'm a professional
swimmer I don't know if you're on your
leader no I mean I'm like you're your
mid-years maybe but that's you who I'm
like yeah but from for like professional
swimming world fair enough but we're
heading to Paris in 2024 so I gotta say
thanks because thank you whenever I'm
having like a bad day thank you very
good thank you thanks for coming I'm
working on it I'm working on it I I had
to make sure I said what's up to
everyone I just like like the thought of
somebody waiting in line for three and a
half hours and I'm not gonna say what's
up it was just like too weird for me to
handle dude
you look good you've been staying in
shape dude I'm here now I'm so sorry for
that mess because I'm sure that shroudy
and they bored the [ __ ] out of everybody
me and Nate holding down as hosts
fired up about this I apologize for the
super late start I think a lot of you
know that I was in the store downstairs
for the last five hours
I just the thought of somebody staying
in line for three and a half hours and
me bailing on them was just unacceptable
so we had a late start but thank you for
everybody who's been jamming by the way
I actually agree with this I apologize
for interrupting the little guy deserves
a chance at something Gary hook it up he
or she just compelled me they're right
send in your three bottle receipts as
well and I'm gonna give you something as
well all three categories that's exactly
right yeah it's [ __ ] the [ __ ] am I
bouging it up for six and twelve only
dust what about the little guy and by
the way it's not the little guy it's 180
[ __ ] dollars plus shipping it's real
money give big shout out to the Blaster
bath because this person completely just
brought me into the realm Three Bottle
people are in the [ __ ] game oh the
last breath sorry I'm like incredibly
incapable of reading big shout out to
the last breath
it's a blaster back
guys I've been [ __ ] taking selfies
for fed answering questions for four and
a half [ __ ] straight hours downstairs
I can't read all right can't [ __ ]
read and thank you John Anita love you
guys thank you for the rest of the team
thank you for all of you guys I know
it's a holiday weekend the whole crew
here that's been with me at the store
thank you for all of you that came to
the store today it was just love lovely
to spread love and positivity and we'll
see you guys all soon thanks guys and
gals see ya
[Music]
foreign
[Music]